dans ce petit village de près de 500
habitants il y a désormais un voisin qui
avec un simple clic peut vous faire
découvrir ceux ci samuel boyau n'a pas
hésité à créer son agence de voyages là
dans sa maison et dans le contexte
actuel il fallait oser j'ai questionné
des agents de voyage aujourd'hui
tous m'ont dit nous ne te lance pas là
dedans ce moment c'est en effet très
risqué mais avec internet aujourd'hui
tout est possible je pars d'une idée
d'un client et je construis son voyage
en fonction de ses idées à lui je pars
pas forcément de voyage tout près que je
dois lui proposer directement ont
construit ensemble le voyage ça c'est
vraiment le concept de tri voyage du sur
mesure mais pas trop cher et sur place
les voyageurs peuvent utiliser cette
application dans chaque journée du
voyage
vous avez les étapes qui sont très
personnalisé puisque par exemple la
visite d'une ville
la première étape c'est d'aller au
parking donc si on va aller au parking
on a la clé les coordonnées du parking
et surtout le gps qui vous y emmène
automatiquement en fait samuel qui est
aussi peintre cible avant tout ce qu'il
appelle les tribus voyageuse des groupes
d'amis ou des grandes familles il leur
propose donc des minibus et des
hébergements adaptés
il ya beaucoup de familles qui partent
en vacances des associations des
collègues etc
c'est l'occasion surtout de fédérer et
puis de se retrouver ailleurs justement
dans un hôtel un petit peu classique
c'est un barbecue le soir c'est une
pétanque c'est ça les vacances aussi
et sans les retrouve dans les locations
de maisons et ça on le retrouve en
minibus quand on est tous ensemble dans
le véhicule
ça son charme aussi un voyagiste
audacieux qui organise des séjours dans
toute l'europe mais aussi des balades en
franche comté ou en alsace
car pour samuel laventure comme le
dépaysement bien sûr se trouvent parfois
au bout de la rue